so when you're walking into a
brick-and-mortar store in the real world
it's pretty obvious that you're gonna
put down some money and you're gonna buy
something is that similar for apps yes I
know if you wish to charge user before
they download your app you can do it in
a simple way first create a merchant
account second set prices for your app
in the developer console third you can
optionally include advertising or use
in-app billing to sell additional
feature or content web links to all
those three stages in the instructor
notes down below it's important to
remember who are you targeting since
this model may limit your app
monetization potential particularly in
developing market you may be able to
achieve greater revenue by using the
freemium or subscription models